[Aplausos]
bueno cuando pensamos en una ciudad
seguro que nos vienen a la cabeza los
edificios coches movimiento
segura que nuestra mente y nuestro
imaginario colectivo con muchísima
agilidad dibuja algo semejante a lo que
se ha dicho pero quiero hablaros de otra
cosa quiero hablaros a todos y todas
vosotras del alma que debe y existe
detrás de las ciudades de los barrios de
los pueblos grupos de personas que
conviven y ostras qué difícil es eso de
convivir cuando pensábamos que lo
complicado en esta vida era vivir ser
plenos felices de repente llega la
convivencia y eso requiere de matrícula
dolor
y es tan importante porque en ese
convivir radica el sentido de que
compartamos escalera de que compartamos
parqués de que compartamos colegio de
que compartamos planeta
radica el sentido de construir
comunidades de convivir y no me refiero
a comunidades de vecinos en las que se
dan auténticas batallas dialécticas para
decidir si ponemos estucado o ponemos
gothel en la pared o si hacemos una
derrama o no no no no no me refiero a
eso me refiero a la comunidad que forma
y conforman ese tercer cinturón de
protección de las cosas que nos rodean
mirad toda persona tenemos unas
competencias tenemos unos aprendizajes
tenemos una mochila que vamos llenando
de mecanismos que nos ayudan a transitar
por nuestra existencia tomando
decisiones es un primer cinturón de
protección que nos ayuda a vivir oa
sobrevivir pero en ocasiones quizás en
muchísimas ocasiones es el primer
cinturón de protección nos falla vamos a
imaginarnos una cosa vamos a imaginarnos
que no estamos hoy aquí es domingo me
levanto por la mañana y me apetece ir a
comprar el pan para desayunar con mi
familia
salgo a la calle compró el pan me voy
dando un paseo por el barrio y de
repente a lo lejos
no soy capaz de distinguir a una persona
que coge y me dice tú estás mal te voy a
partir la cabeza
yo quedaría perplejo a los tres que pasa
rápidamente se activaría mi cinturón de
protección y diría esto tranquilo vamos
para casa vamos a desayunar a pasar el
domingo no te metas en líos seguro que
esa persona ha tenido un mal día
pero puede ser que quien haya tenido un
mal día sea yo puede ser que haya
perdido el sporting es bastante habitual
últimamente o puede ser que lleva una
semana realmente mala que me han echado
el trabajo o que lleva una racha
complicada o quizás que la vida no me ha
sonreído lo suficiente si tengo la
suerte de que me acompaña un amigo de
que me acompaña un familiar ese segundo
cinturón de protección que todos
debiéramos tener que nos personas que
nos quieren que nos cuidan en las que
nos apoyamos pues ese colega o ese
hermano me diría maestro venga no le
hagas caso que seguro que esta persona
ha tenido un mal día pero puede ser que
esté solo un domingo por la mañana pues
sería lo habitual o puede ser que ese
segundo cinturón de protección no esté
no se le espere o no exista o peor aún
que ese amigo me diga usted ha visto lo
que ha dicho el tipo ese vamos a ir a
partir de la cabeza
claro que ocurriría
una pelea la policía nacional una nariz
rota un ojo hinchado una denuncia
todo el sistema institucional al
servicio de resolver algo que parecía
que no iba a ocurrir y va a comprar una
barra de pan aquí es donde entra ese
tercer cinturón de protección porque la
acera de enfrente está maría maría es
una vecina que me conoce de toda la vida
porque desde que eras un pequeñito que
de repente cuando escucha el improperio
que ese elemento me ha dicho dice héctor
tranquilo tranquilo es manolín está como
las maracas de machín no lo hagas ni
caso mamá no me tira pa casa tiempo a
casa
daros cuenta de un pequeño gesto que una
persona hace hacia otra todo lo que
llega a evitar ese es el pegamento que
construye ese tercer cinturón de
protección que construyen las
comunidades
fijaos el 26 10 por ciento de las
personas en este país están en riesgo de
exclusión y pobreza no lo digo yo lo
dice el informe de la red europea de
lucha contra la pobreza que se publicó
el año pasado no voy a entrar a explicar
qué es esto de la pobreza el índice de
exclusión sólo quiero que os queda una
cosa clara esto quiere decir que una de
cada cuatro personas lo está pasando
francamente mal
y ante una realidad así todo lo que
podamos construir institucionalmente que
siendo muy necesario no es suficiente
porque esta falta de cuidado esta falta
de mirada comunitaria lo que hace es que
nos perdemos en muchísimas cosas en
ocasiones solo vemos la puntita del
iceberg de la realidad que algunas
personas están viviendo y no somos
capaces de profundizar en las causas que
provocan tanto sufrimiento
pensad una cosa
necesitamos juntarnos necesitamos
construir cosas colectivas necesitamos
estar al servicio de las demás personas
porque solo así vamos a ser capaces de
transformar lo que nos rodea
son historias de personas que lo que
intentan es encontrar una pequeña
ventana de oportunidad para poder vivir
dignamente son niños niñas y
adolescentes que están alejados de la
felicidad y que han crecido en contextos
vulnerables
son respuestas a un sistema que en
muchas ocasiones sólo sabe decir en esta
ventana no gracias adiós
tenemos una realidad que muchas
ocasiones prejuzga a las personas que
están pasándolo mal que tienen miedo de
quien es diferente y que intentan echar
a quien viene de lejos una realidad que
culpabiliza a quien intenta sobrevivir
vivimos un mundo super rápido un mundo
en el cual no somos conscientes de la
realidad que nos rodea y no siendo
conscientes es imposible que podamos
tomar conciencia porque sólo cuando
somos conscientes de algo podemos tomar
conciencia para intentar cambiarlo y
solo cuando muchas personas viven ese
proceso el cambio está próximo
yo tengo la suerte de formar parte de un
proyecto comunitario que intenta tejer /
conectar muchas realidades y muchas
personas se llamaba mar de niebla y es
un proyecto que se da en un barrio como
pueden ser el barrio de muchas de las
personas que estáis hoy aquí barrios en
los que hay gente que vive bien gente
que tiene contextos más difíciles
durante todos estos años hemos luchado y
trabajado para intentar construir ese
proyecto comunitario y ya hemos
aprendido cosas muy importantes entre
ellas que tenemos que ser capaces de
vencer el individualismo que nos aísla y
que nos desconecta de las personas con
las que cohabitamos nunca habíamos
estado rodeado de tantas personas y
nunca habíamos estado tan solas
hemos aprendido que si no somos capaces
que las personas se conozcan nunca se
van a reconocer cuando voy caminando por
la calle y me encuentro con josé tirado
en el portal tirado en la calle con una
botella de vino rodeado de basura a las
10 de la mañana no soy capaz de ver a
una persona que ha estado trabajando
durante 20-30 años y que como todas las
personas que estamos aquí un día
tiene una pérdida un ser querido que
desaparece
jose entra en una depresión una
depresión de la cual no puede salir y
jose no tuvo al lado a mariah no tuvo
una red de protección que le ayudara a
huir del consumo de una botella de vino
todos los días a las nueve y media de la
mañana
cada persona que suma ese 26 10% tiene
una historia de vida detrás
historias de vida como la de jose como
la de fátima como la de pedro daros
cuenta historias de vida que no se
plantean que pasan a nuestro alrededor y
que no tenemos la capacidad de poder
apoyar porque porque lo desconocemos
porque no estamos conectados con nuestra
comunidad porque solo cuando tenemos
sueños colectivos solo cuando nos
conectamos tenemos la capacidad de
cambiar las cosas
yo soy tremendamente optimista aunque no
lo parezca soy tremendamente optimista
porque sí que creo que se pueden
construir comunidades porque sí que creo
que se pueden cambiar las cosas y creo
que se pueden cambiar las cosas porque
no hace falta ser seres excepcionales
para hacer cosas excepcionales y porque
sé que las utopías del pasado son
realidades del presente y lo sé porque
en el pasado hubo personas que soñaron
convivieron compartieron compartieron y
lucharon por intentar cambiar las cosas
mira que en el año 2011
estábamos pintando arreglando el local
de más de niebla pequeño local que
íbamos a tener y éramos 10 personas
las personas que íbamos por las tardes
los fines de semana una era mi madre
otra mi abuela otro mi hermano la novia
de mi hermano
un éxito brutal pero en el año 2018 el
21 de septiembre 2018 lo inauguramos el
centro comunitario de la entidad un
espacio en el que colaboraron más de 250
personas voluntariamente un espacio de
más de 1600 metros cuadrados por el que
pasan más de 4.000 personas al año y que
es dinamizado por más de 120 personas
voluntarias y profesionales contratadas
que semanalmente se desviven por ayudar
a los demás en aquel lejano 2011 me
acuerdo el sábado por la mañana
estábamos pintando una puerta con
esmalte
quizás el disolvente afectó a nuestra
capacidad sensorial y un compañero me
dice ostras sector somos cuatro gatos lo
coge mire para elige lo estético como
que son los cuatro gatos tea tú no eres
feliz con lo que estás haciendo no crees
en lo que estás haciendo porque tenemos
que estar pensando quién está en quien
no está y no nos fijamos en quién está
y si estamos convencidos de lo que
estamos haciendo si caminamos seguro que
siga sumando muchísima más gente y tanto
que se suma más gente pero no se sumó
porque pintara muy bien aquella apuesta
todo lo contrario es un desastre sino
que se sumaron muchas personas porque
todas las personas tenemos un superpoder
dentro de nuestro cuerpo el problema es
que ese superpoder no se despierta hasta
que no somos capaces de cambiar nuestro
eje de prioridades
y tenemos que estar atentos a las cosas
que pasan a nuestro alrededor para que
ese eje de prioridades empiece a mirar y
empezamos a darnos cuenta de que juntos
y juntas podemos conseguir muchísimas
más cosas son pequeños detalles que
ocurren a nuestro alrededor
voy a hablar de otra historia de un
domingo yo tenía 11 años y estaba en
misa en la parroquia de mi barrio y
pochi el cura de la parroquia que era un
crack coge y pidió un voluntario dijo
algún voluntario y yo que a mí me
encantaba la farándula y bueno yo y
mogollón más de gente no coincidió que
mi hijo venga ven para acá héctor fui
para allá y me dice bueno imagínate que
vienes de comprar el pan es como cuando
los cinturones que vienes de comprar el
pan y que tengo atrás una persona que
está pidiendo querías y jehová está
chupado porque estoy en el primero de
solidaridad
vale no pasa nada le dije hombre pues es
muy fácil yo cogería un churro skin de
pan de que me sobra y le diría toma un
chin kachin de pan que me sobra pero
perfecto de repente me dice
darías lo que te sobra
esta tontería este pequeño comentario
que me hizo me hizo pensar muchísimo y
me hizo darme cuenta de que realmente
damos lo que nos sobra damos lo que no
queremos no compartimos lo que tenemos
a partir de ese momento empecé a pensar
y a repensar y a darme cuenta de muchas
cosas que hacemos porque las hacemos
para que las hacemos como las hacemos y
fue cuando descubrí dónde está el
verdadero superpoder que tenemos y es el
superpoder de la participación
el superpoder de sentirte y ser parte
junto con otros y otras de algo que
vamos moldeando una asociación en el
barrio el barrio en sí mismo la ciudad
el planeta el sentirte parte de la
especie humana
entendí que si queremos podemos y
sabemos vamos a tener la capacidad de
[ __ ] la llave de la participación y
transformar la realidad que nos rodea
porque solo así vamos a ser capaces de
crear comunidades porque solo así vamos
a ser capaces de conocer las cosas que
pasan a nuestro alrededor y cambiar la
vida de las personas porque solo así
vamos a poder levantarnos del cómodo
sillón de la vida que nos hace ver
series constantemente para pasar a hacer
películas películas que cambien cosas
películas que construyan comunidades yo
desde el fondo de mi corazón os animo a
que abráis los ojos a que empecéis a ser
conscientes de lo que pasa a nuestro
alrededor y a tomar conciencia
a cause deis cuenta que seguro en
vuestro barrio que en vuestra vida hay
personas que están intentando crear
comunidad y seguro que esas personas
están pensando ostras si somos cuatro
gatos levantaros actuar sumarnos a ellos
reflexionar hacer que las utopías del
presente sean las realidades del futuro
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]